the top three most extreme forms of
social engineering number one salary
scams a hacker poses as an existing
employee at a company and sends an email
to the payroll department or HR seeking
to change their banking details this
causes the employee's salary to be
redirected to the hacker number two fake
Investments the main goal here is to get
people to throw their money into a fake
investment opportunity there will be
Promises of amazing Returns on
investment and probably somehow I got
rich stories from Shady influencers
number three your package has arrived
the victim gets a text supposedly from a
shipping company containing a link to
claim their package into which they
enter their sensitive personal details
including their credit card info in 2022
the FBI received over 800 000 complaints
related to social engineering the losses
amounted to over 10 billion but how can
we protect ourselves don't trust
strangers online and check their
identity use antivirus software use dual
Factor authentication don't click on
suspicious links and subscribe to our
Channel